und jetzt kommen wir aber zu Ihnen Herr
Hoffmann und dem wichtigen Thema heute
Abend was sie mitgebracht haben sie
wollen doch heute über die
corona-impfung sprechen ja weil es
zeichnet sich ja ab dass die EMA den
Impfstoff jetzt auch für Säugling ich
glaube auch fünf Monate freigegeben hat
ab sechs Monate
und da stellt sich mir natürlich die die
Frage was eigentlich das Ziel dahinter
ist also wen wollen wir denn eigentlich
damit überhaupt noch vor irgendwas
beschützen
wir wissen nicht wir sind natürlich
wieder ein sehr diffuses volatiles
Infektionsgeschehen aber
ich kann mir eigentlich auch nicht
vorstellen dass es sonderlich viele
Menschen gibt die dieses Angebot
wahrnehmen werden und die Art und Weise
wie mit diesem dann doch
medizinisch-technologisch neuartigen
Impfstoff leichtfertig umgegangen wird
wo wir schlicht und ergreifend nicht
wissen was damit passiert in fünf Jahren
in zehn Jahren in 15 Jahren
es ist auch noch mal eine andere
Angelegenheit wenn Erwachsene sich das
freiwillig verabreichen wir können uns
lange darüber unterhalten ob die
wirklich alle notwendigen Informationen
gehabt haben um wirklich zu sagen jo das
war jetzt meine informierte Einwilligung
in der medizinische Behandlung aber bei
bei Kindern stelle ich oder insbesondere
bei Säuglingen stelle ich mir natürlich
die Frage
wer da dann im Zweifel aufpasst dass da
wirklich keine Schindluder mitgetrieben
werden
es gibt natürlich heute schon Impfungen
die Kleinkinder erhalten über diese
berühmte Sechsfachimpfung mit erprobten
Impfstoffen die Krankheiten gegen die da
geimpft sind gefährliche Krankheiten
keine Frage aber das sind halt lang
erprobte
Mechanismen die man sich dazu nutze
macht
und wenn ich mir überlege dass
ja die Studien die laufen halt alle noch
bis 2024 wird er heftig studiert und aus
meiner Sicht ist das schlicht und
ergreifen nichts weiter als ein
fürchterlicher Euphemismus für wir
führen eine Studie am Menschen durch
ohne zu wissen was wir eigentlich machen
sehr harte Vorwürfe sie sind ja auch
Rechtsanwalt für Medizinrecht und wenn
ich richtig informiert bin dann
verteidigen sie auch Menschen die
Impfschäden haben oder die zu ihnen wie
dramatisch ist denn die Lage dass sie zu
diesem harten Urteil über die Corona
Impfung kommen ich sag's mal sag's mal
so wir haben einen stetigen Zulauf von
von Personen
die wir gegenüber dem Staat also in dem
Fall dem LAGeSo vertreten die ihre
Impfschäden gerne anerkannt und bekommen
haben wollen und entschädigt werden und
da muss ich sagen tut der deutsche Staat
so als gäbe ist die gar nicht es dürfte
ist die auch gar nicht geben man wirft
den Leuten so ich kann das nur so wenn
man alle möglichen Steine in den Weg um
sich davor zu drücken
konkret
einer der häufigsten
Varianten des Syndrom da haben sie Leute
die früher Triathlon gelaufen sind die
da nicht mehr mit den den den
Hausschlüssel in die Hand nehmen können
um die Tür aufzustechen die sitzen dann
vor ihnen wie ein Häufchen Elend und
sagen ja und mein Arzt hat es mir
bestätigt dass es ein Impfschaden ist
und man stellt dann den Antrag und man
hört erstmal ein halbes Jahr von den
Leuten nichts mehr gut die haben viel zu
tun keine Frage aber mit dem mit dem
Management dieser dieser folgen man hat
die Leute aus meiner Sicht auch mit
unzulässigem Druck dazu gedrängt diese
diese Impfung zu nehmen ich möchte immer
daran erinnern dass unser geschätzter
Herr Gesundheitsminister auf Twitter vor
einer Weile noch propagiert hat er
könnte das nicht verstehen dass die
Leute eine nebenwirkungsfreie Impfung
das hat er versprochen eine
nebenwirkungsfreie Impfung nicht
annehmen wollen und da bin ich dann
geneigt zu sagen Medikament das keine
Nebenwirkungen hat es hat auch keine
Hauptwirkung also entweder der Kram hat
alle Impfungen auch Nebenwirkungen als
es jetzt nicht nur bei der Corona so es
gibt ja auch bei anderen Impfungen
Nebenwirkungen hä wie das ist ja eine
harte ehrlich gesagt eine harte Aussage
schon zu sagen die corona-impfung ist
eher ein Feldversuch ähm würden Sie denn
dabei Pflichten
man muss erstmal die Emotionen ein wenig
rausnehmen also ich meine jetzt reden
wir über Säuglingen die geimpft werden
sollen bei jeglicher Impfung entscheiden
sowieso die Eltern das heißt der arme
schutzlose Säugling so wie es
dargestellt wird es wird ja nicht
durchgeimpft nicht ganz Deutschland wir
sind ja keine Diktatur wo jetzt jeder
Säugling zwangsmäßig eine Impfung
bekommt das entscheiden immer noch die
Eltern genauso wie für Masern Mumps
Röteln und so weiter also da würde ich
jetzt mal die Emotion rausnehmen das ist
wenn wenn das sozusagen auf eurer
europäischer Ebene entschieden wird dann
ist es ein Angebot das gemacht wird es
ist natürlich kein Zwang und es gibt
mindestens noch drei bis vier Millionen
Menschen in unserem Land die aufs
weltanschaulichen Gründen sagen ich
möchte nicht geimpft werden oder ich
warte auf den russischen Impfstoff dem
vertraue ich mehr oder was auch immer
und wir sind
klassischen todimpfstoff haben möchte
zum Beispiel ja und da wir eine
Demokratie sind dass das möglich unter
da bin ich auch stolz drauf dass sowas
möglich ist dass jeder seine Meinung
haben kann bis hin dazu dass man sagt
ich lasse mich und meine Kinder nicht
impfen generell glaube ich gibt es wenig
also oder ein Beispiel weil sie vom
LAGeSo und von Impfschäden sprachen auch
wir haben in unserer Rehaklinik in
Berlin Menschen die wahrscheinlich im
Schäden davon getragen haben von uns
Ärzten wird das natürlich begutachtet
und wir empfehlen den sofort sich zum
Beispiel bei den relevanten Stellen zu
melden aber auch diese relevanten
Stellen haben
Personalmangel und pipapo das heißt ein
halbes Jahr Wartezeit kann ich
bestätigen dass das dauert die
Anerkennung eines Impfschadens ist nicht
so trivial wie es sich anhört denn das
gehen bei re-syndrom zum Beispiel oder
andere Syndrome andere
mögliche Impfschäden entstehen auch
sozusagen denovo ohne im Schaden durch
ein banalen Infekt kann man ein
gehirnsyndrom entwickeln das heißt es
muss schon nachgewiesen werden oder mit
einer an Sicherheit Grenzen oder eine
Wahrscheinlichkeit über 50 Prozent das
wirklich die Impfung die Ursache dieser
Schadens ist und dass dieser Schaden
nicht ohne Impfung aufgetreten ist so
gewesen ja aber das muss natürlich
nachgewiesen werden sonst könnte jeder
behaupten der bleiben wir einmal bleiben
wir einmal bei diesen Nebenwirkungen
also Herr Hoffmann erzählt von dem warum
sie bestätigen dass es im Nebenwirkungen
im Schäden gibt aber muss sehen in wie
häufig die vorkommen und die Häufigkeit
ohne Impfung vorkommen jemals
sagen dürfen nebenwirkungsfrei oder das
suggerieren dürfen das ist ja schon eine
Frage die sich stellt als wenn er das so
gesagt hat ist das mindestens
unglücklich nicht war ein Medikament ich
würde da ihm wahlpflichten ja da wo ich
sagen würde also Medikament das keine
unerwünschten Strich Nebenwirkungen hat
hat wahrscheinlich auch keine Wirkung ja
also alles hat Nebenwirkungen oder kann
Nebenwirkungen haben und man muss
fairerweise auch sagen wir waren alle
sehr froh dass ein Impfstoff zur
Verfügung war weil wir zu dem Zeitpunkt
sehr dringend einen Impfstoff braucht
und wir waren uns alle bewusst dass
dieser Impfstoff eben nicht über zwölf
Jahre entwickelt worden ist sondern in
nur einem Jahr zusammengebaut ja nicht
wirklich kommuniziert also man muss ja
schon sagen also aber nicht gesagt sie
bekommen einen Impfstoff der ist noch
nicht
der Zeitung lesen konnte konnte konnte
nachvollziehen dass dieser Impfstoff
sozusagen nur deswegen so schnell
entwickelt werden konnte weil
verschiedene Stadien der normalen
Impfstoffentwicklung parallel lief nicht
übersprungen oder parallel liefen und
beschleunigt wurden wo worauf sehr stolz
war noch in Deutschland absolut aber es
wirkt ja mit der Impfkampagne ich
manchmal Günther Jauch war abgebildet
mit einem mit einem Pflaster der war zu
dem Zeitpunkt nicht mehr als geimpft als
war ja schon fand ich jetzt nicht dass
es eine sehr informative Impfkampagne
war sonst war Hauptsache alle gehen sich
jetzt impfen das war ja eigentlich schon
der Zug in diesem Land ja ich glaube da
würde ich ihn bei Pflichten aber es gibt
ich auch aus meinem Bekanntenkreis
Menschen die sich ja nicht haben impfen
lassen die sozusagen diesem Sog
widerstanden haben deren Argumente man
sich angehört hat und auch
nachvollziehen konnte warum ja
beispielsweise wenn jemand sagt ich
möchte lieber auf einen Tod im Stoff
warten und ich finde das ist auch für
mich weil ich nicht nachvollziehbar aber
dennoch ein Standpunkt dafür mal stehen
kann weil sie haben völlig Recht auf
einmal was sie mit Freiland versucht
meinten da fällt mir auch die Pille ein
Ende der 60er Jahre ja als nur als
Beispiel so auch ein Medikament was an
Millionen von Frauen ausprobiert wurde
wenn man so will und man wusste auch
nicht genau was es für unerwünsche
Wirkung haben wenn das nur so als
Beispiel es gibt natürlich immer
Medikamente die erstmal ausprobiert
werden und dann sieht man erst was man
anstellt oder wenn man an Contergan
jetzt denkt aber zurück zum Thema
große Angst macht wenn man das schon
hört ich meine damit nur es ist also ich
verstehe die Sorgen wenn man sagt wir
verimpfen etwas von dem man nichtmals
wissen was in einem Jahr ist oder
vielleicht alone in 10 Jahren also
insofern nehme ich das genauso ernst und
wenn jemand mir sagt er möchte sich
deswegen nicht impfen lassen es ist
meine Pflicht und Aufgabe als Art zu
sagen dass es aus meiner Sicht nicht
nachvollziehbar ich empfehle dir die
Impfung aus diesen Gründen und das a der
erste Grund jemand der dreifach geimpft
ist hatten deutlich niedrigeres Risiko
an einer schweren an einem schweren
Verlauf zu erkranken also
intensivpflichtig zu werden hat auch
einen deutlich geringeres Risiko
trotzdem noch ein Risiko auch an ich sag
mal long Kurve zu erkranken auch eine
Entität die 17 Millionen Menschen in
Europa schon angeblich haben also dass
das nur so als Punkt also ich denke
wichtig ist die Aufklärung und dann kann
jeder Babys natürlich nicht aber jeder
Erwachsene selbst entscheiden was für
ihn sinnvoll ist
man reinholen weil das ist ja ein gutes
Stichwort die aufklär ich finde zum
Beispiel so wie sieht das gerade erklärt
hat da hat man sich ja sehr abgeholt
gefühlt wenn ich jetzt Patientin bei
Ihnen in der Praxis gewesen wäre diesen
Chefarzt aber wie war denn die
Aufklärung also man kann ja nicht sagen
durch die einrichtungsbezogene
Impfpflicht und 2G es haben sich ja
viele Menschen unter Druck gesetzt
gefühlt also auch ich kenne Menschen die
sich nur wegen dem Druck geimpft haben
und nicht aus Überzeugung
ja das war glaube ich damals so es war
ja auch am Anfang auch so dass der
Impfstoff knapp waren das war ein gut
dass man gar nicht rankomme sehr lange
Zeit da hat man Impfstoff aber was ich
geschafft das sozusagen in die Arbeit zu
bringen weil die Logistik dahinter
fehlten
es verändern sich ja die Ziele das ganze
ist ja auch an das Virus bewegt sich ja
auch wir haben da davon geredet dass wir
ungefähr 1000 corona-tote am Tag hatten
in Deutschland nehmen die meisten auch
damals an Corona gestorben sind ungefähr
80% man weiß es immer noch nicht
hundertprozentig es gibt halt immer nur
einzelne Untersuchungen aber bei den
alten Varianten gibt man von ungefähr
80% aus heute ist man wahrscheinlich
eher bei
50%. aber damals gab es halt 1000 Tote
am Tag von insgesamt 2700 die wir haben
in Deutschland also das heißt eine
erheblicher Teil der dann noch oben
drauf kam da war damals also an
krebssterben in Deutschland ungefähr 650
Menschen am Tag wie gesagt Kovac mit und
an zusammen
bei neuen Studien das jetzt mehr
Tumorerkrankung denn jeweils viel
Vorsorge ausgefallen ist genau genau
aber ich sag halt nur das war von der
reinen Menge her eine große Zahl dass
wir damals halt vor allem darauf geguckt
müssen verhindern dass Menschen sterben
völlig richtig heute sterben im
siebentagen Schnitt sind wir so ungefähr
bei 140 das ist auch wieder ein bisschen
angestiegen die meisten davon
tatsächlich nur oder die Hälfte
wahrscheinlich das sind nur mit und ich
an Corona
ja
wobei sich auch nicht genau das ist halt
auch so ein graduelles Ding soweit ich
das weiße Mediziner ob es wirklich mit
oder an war aber
viel viel geringer die Zahl das ist halt
nur eine Todes unter Ursache unter
vielen mittlerweile das Problem was wir
heute haben aus meiner Sicht ist können
wir eine Überlastung des
Gesundheitssystem bekommen oder nicht
droht so was wie eine Überforderung der
Intensivbetten zum Beispiel und da wir
sind bisher nie an dem Punkt gekommen
wobei man glaube ich bis heute nicht
weiß wie na wir da dran waren bei der
Impfung bleiben weil da kommen wir
später noch zu ihm im Zusammenhang mit
alonkovit sie wollte also einmal
ganz genau ich habe das lange lange da
hingeführt sozusagen im Moment was viel
wichtiger ist ist die vierte Impfung
meiner Sicht für die älteren weil die
Älteren sind diejenigen die dann die
Intensivbetten belegen sind halt nicht
die Kinder also wir reden wir reden in
Deutschland von teilweise nur wenigen
Dutzend erst Impfungen am Tag in ganz
Deutschland da werden jetzt nicht wenn
auch kleine Kinder geimpft werden dürfen
auf einmal die Praxen voll sein also die
alten Menschen über 60 70 Prozent von
über 60-Jährigen haben keine vierte
Impfung erhalten und das sind die die
multimorby also viele Erkrankungen haben
können das ist kein Schutz bietet vor
Ansteckung gut aber nochmal du musst
ganz klar sagen die Leute die heute
sagen ihr habt ja trotzdem Kurve
bekommen obwohl die dreifach geimpft den
muss man ganz klar sagen wir haben
kurbelt bekommen ja weil sich das
entwickelt wie das Grippevirus ich sage
es mal vereinfacht aber wir sind nicht
auf der Intensivstation gelandet das ist
der Punkt dass das haben auch die
Impfung versprochen wir diese Impfung
nicht von Anfang an nur so versprochen
es wurde auch versprochen sich nicht
anzuste eigentlich das kann sein aber
das Wichtige ist eigentlich aus meiner
Sicht weil wir über die Überforderung
oder die Intensivstation die volllaufen
können und so weiter das Kollaps
Gesundheitssystems das Wichtige ist und
das hat sich auch nicht geändert
derjenige dabei bleibe ich auch auch
wenn die die Basis wie sie wie einige
sagen noch nicht so ganz überzeugend ist
diejenigen Leute die sich dreifach haben
impfen lassen und die Älteren die jetzt
sich auch noch impfen lassen sollen 60
plus mit der vierten Impfung warum tun
sie das damit sie eben nicht einen so
stark so desaströsen Verlauf das Risiko
für einen solchen Verlauf mit
Intensivstationen eben nicht erleben ja
das heißt die meisten Kurve Infektionen
heute Verlauf die meisten nicht alle von
relativ gelandet starke Plädoyers
gehalten fast schon wie im Gerichtssaal
auch sehr lange wie Rechtsanwälte jetzt
fragen wir doch mehr Hoffmann ob er
jetzt überzeugt ist sie haben jetzt zwei
Leidenschaft warum sieben Unrecht sind
also das ist ja das ist ja aus meiner
Sicht eigentlich auch nichts neues das
sind ja die Sachen die man die man jetzt
auch medial aufbereitet zu hören bekommt
jetzt ist ja man sieht auch den ich sag
mal den Versuch zu sagen naja ob mit
Kobelt oder ankovi das ist ja auch gar
nicht so so wichtig weil das löst ja den
gleichen Lauterbach
im Krankenhaus den gleichen
Arbeitsaufwand aus und das ist wir ich
ich sage nur wie es kommuniziert wird
und diese Außenkommunikation ist der
Teil der mich der mich daran stört und
wir haben in den letzten Jahren aus
meiner Sicht
in erheblichen Teilen ungefähr 70 Jahre
medizinetik über Bord geworfen was sind
die informierte Einwilligungen ärztliche
halbehandlung angeht dafür aus meiner
aus meiner Sicht kein Weg dran vorbei
ich habe unlauteren Druck auf Leute
ausgeübt mit 2G mit Nachweisen mit
diesem mit jenem ich konnte nur da rein
wenn ich wenn ich wenn ich geimpft bin
und wenn ich meinen meinen
gesundheitsaussage finde der
Arbeitsplatzverlust bei der
einrichtungsbezogenen Impfpflicht was
nicht geschehen oder durchgesetzt worden
ist
zum Beispiel haben Sie an uns gewendet
verschiedenen Universitäten die Medizin
studiert haben er wurde aber ganz
gehöriger Druck gemacht dass sie sonst
aus meiner Semester Ausscheiden mein
Physiotherapeut zum Beispiel ist nicht
mehr mein Physiotherapeut wegen der
einrichtungsbezogenen Impfpflicht nicht
weil ich darauf bestanden hätte mir wäre
das völlig egal gewesen aber sie im
verlässlich aber er durfte vom Staat her
nicht mehr also das ist nicht richtig
das ist auf die Menschen wurde Druck
ohne Ende gemacht muss man anderes
Beispiel mal kurz einschieben
Masernimpfung niemand kann im
Gesundheitssystem Arbeiten der nicht
gegen Masern geben das aus ähnlichen
Gründen
das ist etwas wo man auch argumentieren
kann wieso hat er der Mensch vorher
Lauterbach wieso hat er das so
durchgesetzt weil Masern oder warum muss
auch in Kitas jedes Kind gegen Magen
sagen
das ist nur ein Beispiel dafür dass es
da kann man auch schon sagen das ist
auch ein Druck der ausgeübt wurde weil
das ist ja auch fast ein Berufsverbot
wenn ich als Arzt sage ich möchte mich
aber nicht gegen Masern impfen lassen
kann ich nicht in meinem Beruf arbeiten
ja also
das ist ein Beispiel
akustisches letzte Wort auch noch nicht
gesprochen das ist ja das wird man auch
noch sehen wie viele drin
kommen für mich für mich ist vertreten
für mich ist es einfach nur die Frage
hatten die Leute eine realistische Wahl
und wenn ich mir überlege dass wir in
Deutschland am 21 Jahrhundert überhaupt
die Diskussion einer allgemeinen
Impfpflicht aufgeworfen haben alleine
dass wir an den Punkt gekommen sind wo
wir gesagt haben wenn du dich nicht
einer ärztlichen Behandlung mit einem
Medikament das dessen Status ich sag's
mal so fragwürdig ist und da ziehst dann
lebst du als Deutscher in Deutschland
illegal das wäre da dabei rausgekommen
und der Umstand dass wir überhaupt
darüber diskutiert haben das ist leute
Leute in der Politik gehabt die sich
hingestellt haben und mit einer
Leidenschaft geredet haben ja die
ungeimpften und ah und die müssen weg
also
an welchen Punkt sind wir gekommen das
ist
ich brauche muss ja ein bisschen den
timekeeper zu machen ich merke schon wir
sind hier heute sehr leidenschaftlich
unterwegs weil jetzt kommen wir erstmal
zu long kobit dass sie mich das Thema
von Herr Wiehl heute und das ist ja auch
einer der Gründe warum auch viele
Politiker sehr viel Angst hatten weil
long-cover